it's very real it's very real this is a
real thing this is real money and real
people ancestry has brought me here
today to learn a little bit about my
family this is will my boyfriend he's
here for moral support
yes and later we're gonna be trying one
of my ancestors jobs and I have no idea
what it is I know very little about my
family history but there's always been
kind of an element of mystery around it
in some ways I always feel like a piece
of me has kind of been missing so
hopefully today we can just get a little
bit more clarity and open that bad boy
oh okay so a lot of names that I have
already not seen before so it looks like
there's a lot more about my mom's side
of the family because Irene Morris let's
go in here 1885 Virginia Wow
let's go Robert Morris 18-49 Robert
Robertson Morris oh my gosh there's a
photo oh my gosh look at him it's an
incredible mustache Wow I'm just happy
that that's in your gene pool whoa
furniture in general auctioneer singing
oh my gosh I'm nervous now Morris was
known as one of the most successful
auctioneers in the Norfolk area what are
we doing oh my god I know nothing and
I'm to be honest I'm really nervous
about it so I get to be the model that
like shows off the furniture this lovely
chair my heart's beating really fast I'm
not gonna be good at it there's no way
furniture auctioneering
[Music]
hi I'm Andy nice to meet you so I just
found out that my great-great
great-grandfather was an auctioneer so
I'm here to learn all about it and
hopefully give it a shot
fantastic you came to the right place
I'm third generation and the businesses
for generations and we're one of the
last real true auctions meaning you have
to raise a paddle and that's how you
would buy probably the exact way your
great-great great-grandfather
conducted things so everything I've seen
about auctioneering there's the
fast-talking bid that I really nervous
I'm gonna humma-nah humma-nah type of
thing we haven't found that that chatter
helps in terms of increasing price every
auctioneer has their own rhythm their
own cadence their own personality and
you'll find your own rhythm people also
bid difficult at auctions people
someone's been with a finger sometimes
they wink at you there's a lot of
secretive actions and that's something
that I'll try to tell you but that's why
I always scan to make sure I'm not
missing someone how can I help out like
how can I make this easier for Andy we
have somebody that's called a holder out
there so when we display furniture
somebody holds up the furniture shows
the audience I think it's a perfect job
for you I'm just gonna do like a
practice kind of thing you're getting
thrown into and this is the real deal I
mean this is real money with real people
it gets done up there is set in stone in
general you know 500 people sitting in
the audience so this is real I'm gonna
help you as much as possible
[Music]
this is what you're gonna be doing today
I have to admit earlier I felt pretty
confident and right now it's confidence
is very low is it very nervous I think
you're ready to do this
I got a channel my inner Robert
Robertson is making those feelings guys
quick announcement getting up here is a
young lady named Andy Andy discovered
that her great-great great-grandfather
was an auctioneer we thought we'd get
fresh it off for five items this is her
handsome boyfriend wills or good luck
car it is all right hello
wait right into it go ahead all right
we're gonna get right into it we got the
italian-style come of any interest at
150 there you go all right 200 yep 225
250 300 400 500 600 any advance of 750
going once going twice and sold sold 325
sold at 125 sold at 215 225 I made it
and sold 750 s number 171 zero 725 I'm
so sorry
that's crazy I felt like I kept getting
lost so much and actually saying the
numbers but overall that was really fun
I'm so glad that I did it I feel very
fulfilled and very connected to my roots
so I really want to take a moment to
thank ancestry for letting me do this
and letting me learn about my roots and
try something I've never done before I
never imagined myself being in this
position today you were a natural yeah
try something else see what's in your
blood
[Music]